[Music]
it is officially summer and my favorite
part is being able to take my workout
outdoors but you know how heat is it
gets hot and sticky and we've got to
make sure we're replenishing ourselves
so that's why we've teamed up with
celebrity fitness trainer talk show host
extraordinaire amanda klutz and
smartwater to celebrate national
hydration day it's so good to see you
it's so good to see you too thank you so
much for having me i am such a huge fan
of your classes you know i've been
lining up for years trying to get a spot
can you teach me some of the things
we've done in class but here outside
absolutely these moves are things you
can do at home and you don't need any
equipment these are going to be three
moves that really kind of target your
core but also involve your lower body
because the way to get a good core is
through these large muscle groups on the
bottom of your body
all right so you're gonna put your right
hand above your head and your left hand
on your hip all right you're gonna step
forward on that left leg getting deep
into those legs and then you're gonna
twist exhale as you bring that right
elbow down to your left knee
then come back to center and then come
straight back up let's do four on this
left leg
and come back
in the core ma'am right i mean the good
thing is you have to stabilize through
those legs as you twist so you really
get into those core muscles exhale as
you twist it's gonna feel like you're
wringing out your waist
which feels really good especially on
days aren't let's switch sides on days
you might feel bloated you know
sometimes you kind of just need to feel
like yeah twist it out look at this good
form learn from the best learn from the
best i'm not going to lie though i am a
little exhausted right now can we take a
quick water break let's take a hydration
break okay i love it
you know listen the key to any workout
is hydration and smart water with the
added electrolytes it's just such a
crisp and refreshing taste and you need
to bring water with you wherever you
work out all right now that i'm sweating
give me move number two baby all right
we're gonna come out to a nice wide
second position bend your knees come
down to like that little plie squat left
hand goes up above your head right hand
goes down behind your thigh you're gonna
reach over try to grab your ankle with
that hand and then come back up
reach over and come back up so again
you're stabilizing through your lower
body so that your core really has to
tighten in order to work
one more time over to the right let's
switch sides and let me see how you do
on the left okay really good let's see
you can get lower than that
come on come on come on she pushes me
she pushes mine
all right move number three you're going
to have all your weight on this left leg
your right leg's going to be out in kind
of like an extended point position
left hand goes on top of your head right
goes on your hip you're going to bring
your knee up and you're going to twist
and tap your knee into your elbow and
then come back down keep going hey keep
your balance and twist and come back
down again so you're wringing out that
waist working your obliques getting that
waistline nice and tight trying to stay
bent in this leg try not to just like to
really stabilize oh man yeah and then
stretch back so that's good because
you're working your quads and your
hamstrings here as you're trimming your
waistline coming back in and give me a
real twist like really look to the right
and then come back
and then come back today nope never you
don't cheat and working out thank you
for making me feel my strongest my
healthiest can we replenish one more
time can we do a smart water break i
think that's a very very smart idea
let's do it
you know i've been incorporating smart
water into my workouts for years it is
so so important to flood your body with
oxygen as you're working out it only
fuels your workout to be better 100
i'm just curious when you're with your
celebrity clients how often do you
recommend they take a smart water break
i mean as often as you need it right you
need to make sure that you feel good
that you're not light-headed especially
when you're working out outside in the
summertime so it's always important to
stay hydrated you know i think we have
to uncap unconventional taste with smart
water there we go cheers cheers
you